foreign
let me just introduce this session and
then maybe just kick off with some
thoughts about the future of current
money and then when Vince joins we'll
cover off a few other topics so this
session is to look at from inflation to
digital currencies the future of money
to put it lightly is looking
unpredictable
but how can we prepare against economic
disaster if we can't plan ahead
um so when the former lib Dem leader
Vince cable manages to maneuver through
traffic he will be here and we will
cover off a few topics for instance
cryptocurrency
are we moving to a cash flow society and
what is fintech but I said as I say I
want to start off with some thoughts
about where we currently are in terms of
inflation and the cost of living crisis
whether it's a blip or it's normal but
let me just um start off with some
thoughts about
whether or not inflation is here to stay
with us I'm going to give you the first
of probably many caveats I wrote a book
called The Great Economist and the great
Economist JK Galbraith said economic
forecasting exists to make astrology
look respectable
so I would not count on anyone who can
say for certain that inflation has
peaked this is what it looks like but
here's a few things that you might want
to look at to make that assessment so
one of the key things to consider is
inflation is a measure of year-on-year
price change
so the reason this is important is
because just because inflation if you
don't have another shock like Russia
invading Ukraine again next February you
don't get something that's first
double-digit inflation so inflation May
well slow next year to say six percent
or whatever the the forecast currently
are these forecasts again are highly
variable but that doesn't mean that
prices have come down
now you have very now you have higher
cost of living because inflation may not
be 10 but it still could be six percent
and this is important to bear in mind
because this happened in the 1970s so in
the 1970s there were two not one but two
oil price shocks and after the first one
which is after the Yom Kippur War
1973-74 oil prices actually stayed high
and then we had a second shock in that
decade in 1979 with the Iran Iraq war so
the reason I'm pointing this out is if
you needed to get a sense of how the
cost of living your cost of living is
going to be impacted then it's a level
and not just the percentage that we need
to be mindful of and I think the second
thing that I would say about a indicator
you should look for is we often see
headline inflation so this is CPI
Consumer Price Index
there is another measure called core
inflation so this is a measure of
inflation that strips out volatile items
like food and energy because I mean look
at how quickly Energy prices have
fluctuated and how quickly food prices
have fluctuated because unlike the 1970s
the middle which was energy shocks in
the Middle East Russia and Ukraine are
also major exporters of hard and soft
Commodities so things metals like
Palladium food fertilizer wheat so this
means that those are adding to the
inflationary pressures but core
inflation says don't look at food and
energy what is inflation when you strip
those things out so core inflation is a
measure that's trying to pick up how
much of this inflation has become
embedded in the way that firms produce
so core inflation is running at around
six percent and that's very high that's
about three times the bank of England
Target so that measure I think will give
a sense of whether inflation is here to
stay how embedded it is core inflation
can also fluctuate
um so here's my sort of final analogy
for the 1970s the end of the 1970s and
the huge inflation of that period
resulted in a global recession in the
early 1980s
increases and interest rates by Paul
Walker at the U.S fed Central Bank
Governor then he controlled inflation by
raising interest rates the cost of
borrowing so recession in a sense
brought down inflation so
how depressed are we now I'm telling you
we could end up with uh with and and you
know and the the forecasts are we are
headed for Global recession next year
and the UK is probably in recession now
that's at least what the chancellor has
said so but what that does for inflation
is it reduces demand and actually brings
uh price pressures down but this is
what's what's known as sort of known as
the misery index like unemployment
recession or inflation so it is a it is
a it is a turbulent
um time I don't want to
um understate that but I always hope we
can learn lessons from history so finish
with some thoughts on lessons from
history so I mentioned there what
monetary policy uh did monetary policy
operates a bit differently now but I
think what we need to uh hope the lesson
has been learned is monetary policy
needs to hit essentially a neutral level
where it's at the rate that doesn't
depress the economy and doesn't
stimulate more inflation because 80 of
this inflation is imported so it's it's
um it's Global factors
um so monetary policy can act but it
needs to act in that very it's a very
difficult range to hit because what is
the neutral rate of interest you know
before the banking crisis it was about
five percent was on average what the
interest rate was
um we're just not sure what it is now
because growth rate is lower interest
rate might be lower if inflation is very
high do we need to consider that so all
of that makes it quite hard to calibrate
where monetary policy should be I think
this period is closest to the 1970s so
it is unusual but as Mark Twain
reportedly said history doesn't repeat
itself but it does Rhyme so so we do not
have a there are lessons from the 70s
but there are differences as well and I
think one of the
um the main differences is uh very
different ways in which central banks
operate
um and different causes of this of this
inflation so
unfortunately though because these are
supply side shocks as in it's a shock of
energy prices and food prices that
drives our production costs
um there are limited ways that Economic
Policy can try and cushion this so if
you think about a normal risk not
there's no normal recession but a
recession where demand collapses you can
use fiscal policy to support people's
incomes and because prices are down
output is down you can see how it all
works together the problem now is when
you have a 1970 scenario which is like
stagflation High inflation stagnant
economies and recession
prices and output are moving in opposite
directions so you want to support people
who are vulnerable by giving them income
support that pushes up their demand and
that can be inflationary if the if it's
widespread support and it's done on the
basis of government borrowing so pushing
of demand is inflationary when inflation
is the problem and this is why the 1970
stagflation scenario is is challenging
to to deal with in the 1970s monetary
policy what central banks do is very
focused on targeting monetary Aggregates
the money supply didn't work too well
especially in the 80s money is a very
complicated thing as we will discuss in
just a sec and then the UK moved to a
European exchange rate mechanism a fixed
exchange rate and that essentially
dictated a lot of what money the policy
would be so we crashed out of the ERM in
1992 and launched a period of searching
for a new aim and it became inflation
targeting so expectations having a very
clear Target of two percent does mean
that you have more of a sense of where
central banks are headed where the bank
of England is looking for and so I think
that's one way and credibility in
meeting that Target is important now the
bank hasn't always been successful in
meeting that but at least you you get
that letter from the governor to the
chancellor explaining why but that the
regime itself is a lot more transparent
than what we had before and I think that
increases
helps shape Market expectations and that
could help us now because this is a time
in which you do want to know where the
central bank is going to do and not just
think oh you know with a less
transparent regime so actually Vince
cable is in the house everyone
foreign
we're here to talk about the future of
money so if I may maybe if I could um
just ask you
um to to look ahead a bit I've sort of
covered off where I thought um current
inflation and the cost of living crisis
should be but if we look ahead there's
some really interesting Trends and your
your book money and power obviously
takes a a huge a look at the big picture
I recommend all of you pick up a copy of
it but just talk us through what you
think the future of money is headed is
it cashless will there be crypto will
there be things about policy regimes be
great to get your take so to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV